son match des idées confrontation de
points de vue ce soir entre michaël
darmon et pablo pino vivien on va
s'arrêter sur cette décision surprise du
conseil d'état de suspendre les règles
de calcul de l'assurance chômage
elle devait entrer en vigueur au 1er
juillet elles sont finalement repoussée
de quelques mois cela ne remet pas en
question le fond de la réforme le
conseil d'état invoque le contexte les
incertitudes sur la situation économique
liée à la crise sanitaire mais était ce
bien son rôle
on va ouvrir le débat avec nos invités
dans un instant d'abord les premiers
éléments avec mathias arese la réforme
du calcul des allocations chômage
attendra ce mardi le conseil d'état a
suspendu la mesure en urgence dans son
ordonnance
il explique les incertitudes sur la
situation économique ne permettent pas
de mettre en place à cette date ces
nouvelles règles qui sont censés
favoriser la stabilité de l'emploi
la ministre du travail elisabeth bornes
minimise et refuse de parler de
camouflet pour l'une des réformes phares
du quinquennat
nous regardons donc comment rassurer
davantage tant sur la situation
économique que sur la dynamique de
l'emploi
nous préciserons dans les prochains
jours les modalités d'une mise en oeuvre
rapide de la réforme de l'assurance
chômage pour motiver sa décision
l'institution évoque une erreur
manifeste d'appréciation
un fait rare envers l'administration
comme nous l'expliquent paul cassia
juriste constitutionnaliste cole erreur
manifeste d'appréciation
c'est une erreur qui est grossière est
évident qu'ils sautent aux yeux même des
non spécialistes
c'est vraiment un cas de figure
exceptionnel où l'administration a pris
une décision qui ne correspond
manifestement pas à l'objectif que
l'administration s'est assignée ou que
le législateur lui a assigné pour autant
la plus haute juridiction administrative
française ne remet pas en cause le
principe de la réforme elle-même après
cette réponse en référé elle se
prononcera sur le fond d'ici quelques
mois et avec nous pour ce match des
idées ce soir michaël darmon bienvenue
chef du service politique d'europe 1
pablo pino vivien bienvenue responsable
éditorial chez regard merci à tous les
deux elle vous a surpris cette décision
quel d'armand du conseil d'état qui est
tombée hier alors il ne se prononce pas
sur le fond on le répète il se prononce
sur le contexte qui ne serait pas le bon
et c'est assez rare qu'ils le fassent
oui effectivement sens un style
surprenant siens quand on voit la
motivation économique qui a été donc
mise en avant par le conseil d'état on
s'aperçoit que c'est une véritable
verrue irruption dans le débat dans le
débat politique qui n'a pas de du
conseil d'état était quand même nous
avait pas habitué à ce genre d'analysé
en rappelant qu effectivement le
contexte économique comme vous dites ne
se prête pas à mettre en place donc les
le calcul de l'assurance chômage c'est
que ça avait été envisagée par le
gouvernement est telle que ce ver entrer
en vigueur dès dès juillet donc de ce
point de vue là c'est comme un rappel à
l'ordre
au delà des des avis habituel du conseil
d'état de de dire il faut absolument
faire attention à la situation post
coville avec les justement les
disparités qui peuvent donc exister
entre ceux qui sont touchés par parle
par le comice ce qui est non moins l'été
et du coup les les conséquences sur sur
leur emploi
donc de ce point de vue là c'est une
geren une nouveauté et c'est intéressant
parce que le gouvernement dit non non
non c'est pas du tout un camouflé on a
les syndicats qui disent ici c'est
complètement notre victoire mais
effectivement le conseil d'état ne dit
rien sur le fond intérêts ne remet pas
en question la réforme alors il ne dit
rien sur le fond ça l'endroit pas moi
une première victoire pour les syndicats
ça c'est certain
il ya un point qui l'a que le conseil
d'état a mis en exergue et qui est assez
intéressant
c'est en fait le décalage entre l'entrée
en vigueur qui devait se faire au 1er
juillet et la fameux le fameux bonus
malus pour les entreprises qui feraient
trop de contrats courts qui lui
montrerai en
en 6 en vigueur qu'à partir de 2022 et
en fait ils le conseil d'état dit en
gros bah c'est pas possible en fait de
pénaliser en fait les les gens en fait
qui enchaîne des contrats courts
alors que vous ne pénaliserait les dès
le 1er juillet que vous ne pénaliserait
les entreprises qui pratiquent ce genre
de contrats courts qu'à partir de 2022
donc c'est en ça en fait que c'est juste
entre guillemets à un sursis après il ya
quand même le fond de la remarque de
forme du conseil d'état c'est à dire que
effectivement il considère qu' on est en
sortie de crise sortie de crise
sanitaire mais peut-être début de crise
économique avec un certain nombre de
gens en fait qui sont sans emploi et que
faire passer quelqu'un qui gagne 880
euros
le faire passer à 680 euros et imaginer
que ça ça va lui permettre ça va forcer
à avoir un cdi le conseil d'état dit bah
non en fait tout ça n'est pas très
sérieux
en fait ce sont les motivations de du
drame delà de la réforme que le conseil
d'état a attaqué et en cela c'est
exactement tout l'argumentaire qui
avaient été déployés par l'ensemble des
organisations syndicales sauf la cftc
est donc ça ça paraît enfin je vois pas
trop en fait comment il pourrait revenir
parce qu'en plus on sait très bien que
d'ici la fin d'année l'unedic dit il va
y avoir 9.2 de chômage 9 % de plus de 9%
de chômeurs je vois pas trop en fait
comment d'ici la fin de l'année du
conseil d'état pourrait considérer tout
d'un coup que un bond à la situation
s'est améliorée et on va pouvoir l'a
passée donc il serait à l'abri de ne pas
en fait tu ressens sur est enfin heureux
différé en fait l'application si jamais
ils voulaient la remettre à la rentrée
et c'est fou parce que des économistes
avaient alerté sur cette réforme et
quelques mois sur ce plateau recevait
elie cohen que vous le connaissez sans
doute et il nous disait ceci pourquoi at
on voulu faire la réforme du chômage
parce qu'on avait découvert qu'il y
avait certains dispositifs qui étaient
excessivement favorable et que la
dynamique de retour à l'emploi n'était
pas aussi forte qu'on pouvait l'imaginer
ça cela va très bien dans un contexte où
votre problème c'est de nourrir la
croissance nous dit il c'est de
faciliter le retour à l'emploi est de
résorber les déficits du passé ce n'est
absolument plus le contexte
actuellement nous avons
dit elie cohen donc que l'on abandonne
la réforme du chômage pour moi c'est une
évidence et ça n'a pas été pour le
gouvernement
non ça n'a pas été plus gouvernement
parce que ça vient se heurter à une
volonté politique cette fois-ci poste
qu'ovide de dire nous allons continuer à
réformer jusqu'au bout ce fameux nous
allons continuer à réformer jusqu'au
bout que tous les présidents à ce stade
dit quinquennat à la fin martèle donc de
ce point de vue là il ya eu cette idée
ce volontarisme politique qui a dit on
va quand même passer en force ce qui est
intéressant c'est que au fond le conseil
d'état comme d'autres instances à chaque
fois mettre le point aussi sur la forme
la manière dont les textes sont faits il
y a une il ya eu une sorte de
précipitation on l'a vu encore avec
l'article 24 de la loi sécurité globale
là aussi il y a un il ya des remarques
ont été faites et si des censures sur le
fait que le texte est mal ficelé va trop
vite ne correspond pas un oubli d
arrêter le cas pour la loi via leçon il
y a un à globalement il y as je dirais
non
un regard un peu sévère sur la façon
dont le gouvernement ficelles les textes
souvent parce qu'il faut aller vite
parce qu'il faut répondre à cette
injonction politique qui consiste à dire
on va aller réformer jusqu'au bout parce
qu'on sait très bien que depuis le lot
le premier confinement depuis l'annnonce
de la suspension de la réforme des
retraites est bien au fond le
quinquennat en termes de réformes
structurelles profondes et arrêté et là
l'assurance chemin et c'est en ça c'est
aussi un pour le coin camouflet
politique c'est à dire que le
l'assurance chômage étaient brandies par
le gouvernement comme étant la réforme
qui allaient attester que évidemment on
continue à réformer et là c'est
effectivement encore une fois à l'arrêt
donc on ne pourra même pas mettre en
avant on pourra pas on voit pas comment
jusqu'à la fin de cac et là il pourrait
avoir d'autres textes emblématiques qui
montre des réformes de structure
d'autant que là une des raisons pour
lesquelles il avait réussi en fait plus
ou moins à la essayer de le faire passer
de
de mettre ce début de date en vigueur le
1er juillet c'était qu' il n'y avait pas
de dialogue social mais surtout les
syndicats comme il y avait la tête du
coc vide le confinement etc
les syndicats avaient pu mettre
personnes dans la rue je pense que en
septembre
si jamais ils remettent sur le tapis
cette réforme de l'assurance chômage
là tout d'un coup toutes les centrales
vont dire maintenant on va mettre tout
le monde dans la rue parce qu'il est
hors de question que ça passe après je
vous entendez dire michael que le
gouvernement voulait continuer à
réformer le problème c'est que en fait
je pense que pour beaucoup de gens qui
ont voté pour emmanuel macron ils
attendent juste qu'il commence à
réformer parce que hélas pour l'instant
il ya très peu de réformes structurelles
qui émane et le maquereau a réussi à
mettre en place
on se souvient de la réforme des
retraites cas qui est un peu passée aux
oubliettes à cause du à cause du coc
vide
donc il ne fait pas il va falloir non
mais il va falloir que s'il veut se
prévaloir d'un bilan de réformateurs une
heure pour le pour la présidentielle de
2000 22 il va quand même falloir qu'ils
puissent prendre c'est des choses
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui peut présenter
bon à part avoir dépensé beaucoup
d'argent a pas mal d'endroits notamment
pendant le coc vide etc ne peut pas il
peut pas dire voilà j'ai réformer
structurellement quelques endroits de la
chose la société surtout que le conseil
d'état en voile avertissement sur l'état
de la société
le contexte se prête pas est une formule
bon évidemment dans le style très
pondéré du conseil d'état mais qui est
quand même une phrase très forte c'est à
dire que attention à l'état de la
société qui sort de cette période dans
la pandémie qui a été bien évidemment un
bouleversement mais qui sortait avant du
conflit des retraites et qui sortait
avant de la crise et gilet jaune
donc on est quand même sur un
quinquennat qui est traversée en coupe
longitudinale par des crises et un
moment donné le conseil d'état dit
attention les français sont pas capables
d'absorber alors qu'on est au moment
justement où une fois de plus
politiquement il ya une volonté
d'accélérer pour aller sur la ligne la
dernière ligne aile
finale espérée au rush final pour la
campagne présidentielle mais je voudrais
qu'on vienne maintenant sur ce feu vert
qui a été donnée tout à l'heure par
bruxelles au plan de relance français la
présidente de la commission européenne
est venu l'annoncer en personne à paris
tout à l'heure lors d'une rencontre avec
emmanuel macron à l'elysée avant d'en
parler avec vous sur ce plateau on va
accueillir dans ce match eric heyer
économiste à l'ofce de bienvenue et
merci d'avoir accepté cette invitation
dans le match des idées la validation ce
plan dépend des si je comprends bien des
conditions de fléchage de l'argent qui
allait être donné est ce que ces
conditions vous semblez bonne et qu'elle
est et elle exactement
oui il fallait il fallait un peu
conditionné alors il y avait à la fois
les le fléchage est aussi quelque part
le financement de ces de ces mesures
on voit bien que pour le financement
c'était les pays bas qui justement
pouvait freiner parce qu' il allait
recevoir quasiment rien et ils devaient
tous même contribué à ce plan pour le
rembourser et donc je pense qu'il y
avait aussi les les ressources propres
qui ont été mis en place et à dire des
impôts ni taxe carbone aux frontières
une taxe sur les géants du numérique une
taxe sur les égarements les entreprises
donc pour avoir en tout cas la corde et
des néerlandais sinon ça serait pas
passé et puis il fallait aussi ciblé ccc
ces mesures il y avait une autre
condition pour les italiens s'étaient
que on met à la tête de l'italie sans
doute quelqu'un qui était plus crédible
pour la commission européenne il faut je
pense que avoir ça en tête et l'arrivée
de mario draghi en italie est sans doute
le bain dans va dans ce sens là et
ensuite il fallait bien sûr là j'en
viens à votre question le psy blessure à
la fois des enjeux de demain
c'est-à-dire la transition écologique
la réduction des inégalités donc ça
c'était et une partie de compétitivité
est également ciblé dans des pays qui
était le plus en difficulté donc c était
cela il y avait à la fois quelque chose
d'assez keynésien c'est à dire que
globalement les pays qui sont en
difficulté on pense à l'italie l'espagne
à celles qui vont le plus bénéficié de
ces de ces fonds et on va leur demander
de le faire dans
des éléments qui sont liées aux
inégalités et à la transition
énergétique
alors pour qu'on comprenne bien la
mécanique en validant le plan français
bruxelles car en garantie dans le même
temps donc une enveloppe de 40 milliards
d'euros c'est ça qui vont directement
pour la france exactement
donc en gros globalement alors enfin ces
implants ont dit de 750 milliards mais
attention sous ses 750 milliards y en a
à 390 on va dire 400 pour arrondir qui
sont des subventions d'accord et le
reste ce sont des prêts et donc les
prêts si on les accorde il faut les
rembourser en revanche les subventions
ben c'est pas parce que vous avez touché
beaucoup plus que les autres que vous
allez devoir payer plus que les autres
dans ces subventions la france dans sur
ces 400 milliards va toucher 40
milliards le l'allemagne aux alentours
de 30 milliards et les deux gros
gagnants sont l'espagne et l'italie qui
vont toucher à peu près 80 milliards
compte beaucoup plus on voit les
pays-bas touche à peine 6 milliards cinq
convois qui vont très très peu touchés
alors c'est la 5ème puissance et donc
ils auraient pu les contribuer de façon
conséquente
donc voilà dont 40 milliards ça
représente dont 40 au sens du plan de
relance français plan de relance qui a
été voté de 100 milliards donc on a
commencé à les dépenser même va
commencer à dépenser c'est c'est ces 40
milliards alors qu'on a touché et qu'on
va toucher qu'une petite partie en
juillet il est le premier chèque par me
pardonnez moi l'expression arrivera
quand pour la france en septembre c'est
ça ouais voilà donc bruno le maire et
c'est de la voir le plus tôt possible
on en veut dire qu'aujourd'hui séguin
pas ça le problème c'est à dire que
globalement les taux d'intérêt sur la
dette publique étant extrêmement faible
notamment en france 1 me tourne aux
alentours de zéro des fois c'est zéro -
des précisions plus mais à l'horizon de
dix ans donc globalement bon c'est sûr
que plus tôt on a le chèque mois on aura
à s'endetter mais puisque on s'endette à
0 globalement c'est pas tellement
l'enjeu aujourd'hui c'est plutôt un
affichage des déficits et des dettes
publiques même si aujourd'hui la
commission européenne intègre
directement ces 40 milliards et donc on
va les sortir de
de notre déficit donc je pense que bon
c'est pas si important que ça on n'est
pas à quelques mois près le fait qu' il
aura fallu attendre un an avant que
l'europe valide des plans de relance
nationaux pour vous c'est pas un sujet
c'est pas un souci si alors on voit bien
que l'idée effectivement on l'europe
était le finalement la première à
émettre cette idée de plan de relance
est assez rapide
c'était l'un sous l'impulsion de deux du
duo merkel macron on voit que les états
unis byden est arrivé bien après et a
fait des plans de relance bien plus
rapide est bien plus important donc
effectivement là de ce point de vue là
on est un peu ridicule conscience
comparé aux états unis bon mais c'est le
fait qu'on n'ait pas une europe
on n'est pas les états unis d'europe
c'est à dire que globalement il faut que
ça passe par tous les parlements il faut
que ce soit validé avant par le tous les
présidents donc ça met énormément de
temps à heureusement encore une fois que
globalement les taux d'intérêts
aujourd'hui sont faibles et que la
banque centrale aide à à financer les
états et donc du coup pas ce plan de
relance est le fait il arrive un peu
tard on ça pose un tout petit peu moins
de problèmes puisque finalement on
s'endette aujourd'hui à 0 mais oui ça
peut poser problème dans l'avenir donc
il va falloir qu'on réfléchisse à des
procédures qui sont qui voit bien plus
rapide mais c'est tout de même une
avancée en terme de solidarité entre les
états européens
sauf que politiquement et est restée
avec nos eric heyer on va continuer la
discussion en plateau évidemment je vous
laisserai intervenir à nouveau mais
politiquement cette lenteur européenne
n'est peut-être pas sans conséquence
michael darmon c'est non parce que bien
évidemment plus tard des subventions
arrivent on peut tomber sont injectés
dans l'économie et les effets se feront
sentir et on a bien compris qu'il ya
maintenant une course eu une course
contre la montre pour savoir si on est
dans une logique de reprise économique à
la rentrée ou pas et déjà des
indicateurs parfois contradictoires
certains disent on va voir dans une
forte reprise du jeu
je vais encore augmenter dont bien
évidemment ça ça participera aussi je
dirais de l'outil de discours de fin de
mandat
pour emmanuel macron qui je vous le
rappelle à partir du 1er janvier 2022
sera président de l'union européenne
donc bien sûr il ya un puissant levier
on verra alors si ça jour un effet de
vie en effet de ré de boulet au tremplin
ça on verra bien le contexte politique
mais parce qu'avec l'europe c'est
toujours sensible mais en tout cas c'est
effectivement c'est important pour les
économies intérieures moi ce qui me
frappe surtout c'est qu'au fond on s'est
un petit peu quand même amusant de voir
ce qui s'est passé dans la cour de
l'elysée aujourd'hui avec président la
comédie le président de la commission et
le président français parce que on
imagine mal que depuis des mois le
président république française soit
transit dans son bureau à attendre la
réponse de la commission
bien évidemment il sait que c'est validé
on le sait que c'est validé depuis
longtemps mais ce qui est intéressant
c'est que la président de la commission
européenne a besoin de se refaire une
santé
elle a été très malmené pendant pendant
la pandémie elle-même a reconnu les
difficultés ne m'accuse pas dans la
gestion d'un commandé des masques
ensuite dans la gestion de l'accès est
elle même a été et sur la selle est
extrêmement contestée elle est critique
et donc en faisant tout d'un coup sa
scénographie cette tournée européenne
pour aller donner en quelque sorte le
chèque symboliquement aux états membres
elle même veut réaffirmer une forme de
je dirais de leadership qu'il est bien
difficile de manière donc pour moi c'est
une scénographie essentiellement
politique un point intéressant bien sûr
c'est une opération de com à la à la
commission européenne ils appellent ça
le 22 retour parce qu'elle fait le tour
des pays européens comme ça il a donné
des bons points en disant regardez c'est
fantastique ce que vous avez fait on a
bien dialogué ce que vous avez dit c'est
assez intéressant que vous avez dit oui
ça a mis un an il ya eu un temps en fait
de tractations pour que ces plans de
relance soient soient validées cia c'est
la députée européenne manon aubry
qu'avait
mis en sueur sont sur les réseaux
sociaux des documents en fait
d'engagement de la france vis-à-vis de
la commission européenne et moi c'est ça
car mon avis qu'il faut pas oublier
nonobstant les fléchages là selon
lesquelles ça c'était les derniers
ajustements mais en fait il ya quelques
mois
moi je lis le sas était dans le document
donc avait envoyé la france à la
commission européenne la france disait
que elle s'engageait à resserrer
l'ouverture des droits pour la location
au chômage avec un retour à six mois de
travail minimum pour les lisibilité
comme rechargement elle s'engager aussi
à durcir la dégressivité des allocations
chômage et dans le même document il
disait aussi que elle s'engageait à
faire une réforme des retraites avec
explicitement comme fin comme objectif
l'objectif financier
donc en fait tout ça c'est en fait dans
le plan de relance c'est ça aussi qui a
permis à ursula von der leyen et à la
commission européenne de valider plan de
relance français
donc en fait le sud le débat qu'on avait
juste avant d'élire les bien sûr c'est
aussi pour ça en fait qu'ils ont qu'ils
ont voulu faire passer un peu au pas de
course
cette réforme de l'assurance chômage
cela confirme encore plus l'aspect de on
va dire directement dans cette politique
puisque comme la réforme de la retraite
des retraites ne reviendra pas donc
avoir la foi n'est qu'un caire le plan
de relance n'est pas annulée pour autant
dans tout ça ce sont des dés ce sont des
des jeux de rôle et on voit bien qu
effectivement à côté de cela vous avez
aussi une europe qui aujourd'hui est
d'ailleurs une fois plus ce sera un des
enjeux de la présence française qui a
aussi fait éclater les mails et les
digues budgétaire on ne parle plus de
ces fini les trois présences en c'est
terminé c'est maintenant on est quand
même dans la période de l'argent encore
magique mais qui va commencer à
s'arrêter le fameux quoi qu'il en coûte
qui va commencer forcément s'arrêter
mais ont plus personne l'ayant l'on sent
bien dans les discours politiques qui ce
prix qui s'affûte pour pour 2022 que
plus personne intègre cette critique la
vis à vis de l'europe une dernière
petite chose il faut pas oublier que
maintenant les plans de relance doivent
être validées par les états ans par les
états membres nous ça va passer à
l'assemblée nationale etc
et ça c'est vrai que quand j'ai entendu
le discours tout à l'heure de emmanuel
macron depuis celui de d'ursula von der
leyen
à présent qu'il avait un peu oublié que
ben y avait quand même un minimum de
souveraineté nationale et que ben il
faut que les parlements différents
nationaux valide les le plein d'animaux
eric heyer sur ce chapitre
non mais je suis d'accord inscrits et à
ce qui a été dit c'est que globalement
effectivement les réformes dont vous
avez parlé au cours d'après un parti
c'était un tout petit peu pour rassurer
nos partenaires la commission européenne
mais aussi les allemands l'ont qu'on
continue à réformer mais c'était un peu
un jeu de rôle là il assez facile de
dire c'est le conseil d'état où c'est un
certain nombre d'éléments qui nous ont
pas permis de faire ces réformes là mais
elles sont toujours dans dans les tuyaux
et ça je pense qu'il y aura toujours
cela c'est à dire qu'on va vers plus de
solidarité d'un côté mais il va falloir
montrer un peu patte blanche de l'autre
donc c'est un jeu au niveau repères et
voilà pour ce chapitre merci beaucoup
eric heyer d'avoir participé au match
des idées on va continuer ensemble sur
ce plateau ne pouvait pas se quitter
sans dire un mot et même plus qu'un mot
des élections régionales et notamment du
duel qui s'annonce en paca en région
provence alpes côte d'azur mariani
muselier jonathan du prix s romane vous
dit quand un calme et suivent
l'entre-deux tours on regarde leurs
reportages et on en parle ensemble juste
après cet homme a rebattu les cartes des
régionales en paca jean laurent fait
lydia champion des écologistes et de la
gauche dans le sud près de 17% des voix
au premier tour
mais l'homme qui souhaitaient se
maintenir aura plié sous la pression des
barons nationaux de la gauche
en moins de 24 heures croyez bien que
personne n'a plus de peine que moi à
vous dire et avant le dire avec
insistance ce soir et on régionales
dimanche
je voterai pour renaud muselier pour
battre mariani et s'attriste courante
ce fonds républicain complique
sérieusement la tâche du candidat du fn
thierry mariani je pense que c'est un
sacré challenge à relever
j'avais mes souvenirs classiques sont
loin mais à vaincre sans péril on
triomphe sans gloire
en tête le soir du premier tour à 36%
des voix
il est sept à huit points dessous des
estimations des sondages messi parce que
c'est les régionales alors cours
mirabeau à aix en provence l'ancien
ministre de nicolas sarkozy peine à
cacher une certaine amertume face au
retrait de la gauche
l'histoire de 2015 semble se répéter à
nouveau une fois de plus socialistes
communistes macro nist mode adhérents du
modem et républicains se retrouvent
ensemble pour essayer le faire en sorte
que ceux qui arrivent en tête ne puisse
pas être élue je vous remercie
le candidat du fn sans véritable réserve
de voix pour le second tour
adapte donc sa stratégie partir à la
chasse aux abstentionnistes
selon l'ifop 71 % des électeurs du et
rennes ont boudé les urnes dimanche
dernier à chaque fois que quelqu'un vous
fait comprendre qui veut voter pour vous
il faut lui dire d'amener ses voisins
ses cousins sa famille voilà c'est
aujourd'hui c'est plus un travail de
fourmi mais c'est un travail que chaque
personne qui nous soutient doit faire
s'il le peut
[Musique]
je
autre ambiance au palais des congrès de
toulon le président sortant renaud
muselier donne son dernier meeting de
campagne avant le second tour
[Applaudissements]
devant 700 personnes survoltées il fend
la foule telle une rock star donnait
perdant dans tous les cas de figure
avant le premier tour renaud muselier
entend montrer que la dynamique a changé
de camp avec de précieux soutiens sur
scène à commencer par hubert falco le
maire de toulon ou immoraux nos que le
président donne une belle région façon
stand-up sans note le président sortant
vante son bilan
on n'a pas arrêté matin midi et soir à
22 heures après avoir redressé les
finances et on nous a craché dessus
matray midi et soir mais regardez il
s'adresse aussi aux abstentionnistes et
n'oublie surtout pas de cajoler la
gauche qui se retire à son profit je
vais bien compliqué
quant à thierry mariani l'adversaire de
renaud muselier ciblées à plusieurs
reprises
comment sur les rochers sur neuf fois de
notre adversaire principal écrit je
remarque la sécurité partout et comment
tu vas faire ailleurs
mais en s'affichant aux côtés d'hubert
falco maire de toulon artisan du
rapprochement avec lrm récemment parti
des républicains
renaud muselier adresse en creux un
message aux élèves sa stratégie de
rassemblement au niveau local a payé
contre l'avis des états majors parisiens
on a toujours parlé du local voilà et
sur le national je suis passé deux fois
en commission nationale d'investiture où
je n'ai que 3 voix contre sur les 68 ont
voté vous penchez vous passez local s'il
vous plaît au moins voilà quatre gènes
chez pensez vous que la région se
gagnera dans les comités stratégiques de
l'eau partie la région elle va se gagner
pour le territoire
thierry mariani et renaud muselier
jetteront leurs dernières forces dans la
bataille jusqu'à dimanche une bataille
que les deux hommes refusent désormais
de nationaliser loin des appareils
l'élection doit selon lui se régler en
paca voilà pour ce beau reportage de nos
équipes sur place pablo pied vivien
depuis le retrait du candidat écologiste
c'est quand même a priori plutôt bien
parti pour renault mise au lit
oui d'ailleurs votre reportage le montre
assez bien du côté de renaud muselier
tout le monde est tout sourire on le
voit il est relativement triomphant
alors que quand on va du côté de
mariannhill le dépité il assez dépité et
à ces défaitistes
non ce que je trouve intéressant dans ce
qui se passe dans le dans le pack à ses
devoirs que ce front républicain en fait
qu'on nous avait dit chancelant qu'on
nous avait dit fissures et on nous avait
même parfois
voilà qui n'existait plus et moi en fait
il existe encore enfin c'est à dire que
en fait il existe encore au niveau des
états-majors
c'est à dire que il est hors de question
pour à la fois quelqu'un comme jean luc
mélenchon ou pour julien bayou le patron
des verts ou pour olivier faure le
patron du parti socialiste de de renier
en fait le front républicain qu'il faut
faire face à thierry mariani après au
niveau local c'est un peu plus compliqué
c'est à dire qu'on l'a vu jean-laurent
félicia il a un peu il s'est posé des
questions pendant pendant un moment et
on pense que c'est sous pression des
états majors parisiens qui là qu'il a
finalement cédé et qui s'est finalement
retirée après tout la question est si ça
qui va falloir regarder dimanche et que
vont faire les électeurs
est ce que les électeurs de jean laurent
fait l'exact est ce que eux aussi en
fait comme les états majors vont tenir
bon ils vont dire banon va aller voter
muselier contre thierry mariani et ça
rien n'est moins certain parce que c'est
vrai que on a vu beaucoup d' enquêtes
d'opinion qui montrait que finalement
les électeurs ils avaient plus envie en
fait de ne pas voter
exactement la liste pour laquelle il
avait envie de voter les français qui en
ont marre de ce front républicain exact
que les martys lui qu'on le pense ce
sont les électeurs qui est qu'ils ont
assez et s'explique d'ailleurs une
partie de certainement de aussi de la
désaffection et d'abstention record
c'est le sentiment que toutes les
mécaniques électorale est entre soi les
accords sont considérés comme étant des
des magouilles et d
la cuisine électorale et qui ne l'est ne
les concerne pas ce qui est intéressant
c'est dans ce deuxième tour c'était
cette élection alors en provence alpes
côte d'azur c'est que c'est vraiment la
région test c'est à dire que glass est
en train de se constituer une pour la
première fois une droite ma chronique
locale organisée sur les barons de la
droite traditionnelle qui sont passés
chez makro c'est à dire muselier falco a
tout mon estrosi à nice
versus d'autres qui sont restés dans le
camp des républicains donc le la la
bagarre las planas tensions à droite qui
se joue entre prom acronis et en team
acronis trouve son point d'ordre dans ce
dans cet immense à tous les projecteurs
sont braqués sur ça c'est effectivement
la deuxième chose c'est que deuxième
aspect c'est que une fois de plus et on
voit on voit m mariani commence déjà un
petit peu à la l'accréditer c'est que
une fois de plus marine le pen se
retrouve en se heurte au plafond de
verre et cette fois ci en double vitrage
c'est à dire que effectivement alors que
les sondeurs enfin peut être un jour se
poser la question donnée est encore
quelques semaines le rn très haut dans
plusieurs régions en réalité c'est un
cetain c'est un rassemblement national
en retrait on recule
et de ce point de vue là c'est aussi un
test pour elle ce n'est pas une bonne
une bonne nouvelle à un an de l'élection
présidentielle sachant que la victoire
annoncée supposé attendu en région paca
pour marine le pen devait lancer sa
dynamique donc présidentielle de ce
point de vue là il ya aussi un test très
important pour l'année prochaine qui se
joue ces jours-ci une résidence ronde
pour conclure et après il faut faire
très attention il ya la question de
l'abstention en fait et c'est à moi je
vaux ce que je vois c'est que depuis le
premier tour de l'élection régionale
il ya une attention qui est énorme en
fait qui a été un cas a été porté en
fait sur ces régionales et
départementales
donc on n'est pas à l'abri en fait qui
argue un en fait de participation pour
le second tour d'autant plus que d'une
part ça n'avait pas été anticipée
l'abstention et d'autre part
le tout le rn et un des partis qu elle
aussi le plus pâti de cette abstention
est on y reviendra merci merci à tous
les deux d'avoir participé au match des
idées fin de cette émission demain à ma
place ce sera alexandre poussard dès 18
heures moi je vous retrouve justement
dimanche soir à 22h30 pour une nouvelle
édition spéciale des chaînes
parlementaires autour de ce second tour
des élections régionales et
départementales je serai là aussi aux
côtés de brigitte boucher demain 7h30
bonjour chez vous vous retrouvez au
rayonnement de chimie qui recevra
notamment eric piolle la maire
écologiste de grenoble je souhaite une
excellente soirée sur public sénat